SPEAKER: Thank you,
everyone, so much for coming
to today's FoodTalks
with Angélique.
And we also have a professor
of gastronomy with us
today, Peter.
Angélique, do you want to tell
a little bit about yourself
and why you're here and
what you'll be doing?
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Well, we
are coming both from Holland.
We work often together,
gastronomy and all kinds
of flavors.
I learned in the
beginning from Peter
because he has a restaurant
named the De Echoput.
It's difficult for you
to tell [INAUDIBLE]..
PETER KLOSSE: Yes.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
Yes, yes, yes.
And so it started with all being
aware of all kinds of flavors.
And that's why we worked already
a long time ago together.
And now in Holland I'm one of
the two female master chefs
from about 150 master chefs.
I think I'll go a little bit
over here because the sound is
not so good.
Can you hear me good like this?
OK.
Great.
So in Holland, I'm one of
two female master chefs.
That's quite unique.
I hope in the
United States there
are lot more female chefs.
But what I'm doing is the art
of creative thinking in flavor,
in flavor matching and
flavor combinations.
So I'll tell you a little story
about culinary creativity,
and then I'm going to make
a flavor painting with about
20 components so you can
experience all kinds of flavor
pairings and flavor matches
which you might think,
I couldn't imagine that
combination has whatever,
made in heaven.
So that's what I'm doing.
Peter will explain why
some combinations have
a special effect in your mouth.
But before we do
that, Peter wants
to tell a bit about
himself and then
we'll start with the
presentation afterwards.
PETER KLOSSE: OK.
Thank you.
She already mentioned a lot.
I have my own hotel
and restaurant.
I developed the
whole flavor theory.
I think flavor is something
that is really tangible, that we
can measure.
And I've got a PhD in
flavor classification.
It's only classification
model on flavor in the world
and it really works.
So we've found a way
to really describe
flavor in objective terms.
So what Angélique is doing with
creativity actually is based
on a very factual thing, so
things that Googlers must like
because there is a real
algorithm, there a real model,
there is real objective
thinking behind it.
So what she is doing is
showing a beautiful painting.
She's going to create a
beautiful painting right here
and then in the meantime,
I will discuss a little bit
on the objective side of it.
So these are the ground rules
of flavor composition here.
So that's what we
want to show you.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
So first I'm going to start
with a little presentation
about creative thinking and not
about brainstorming, but about
dreamstorming.
And then I'm going
to make the painting
and afterwards we'll do a little
bit of culinary mind mapping
so you'll be able to make
your own flavor combination
in a couple of minutes.
So who loves to cook?
OK.
Well, I'm so happy.
That's the reason why
you're here, I think.
OK.
Let's start.
For me, the sky is the limit.
And the story about
creative thinking
is very important before
you go into flavor mixing
because a lot of times we say,
OK, maybe it's not possible
or we see a lot of
issues on the roads,
maybe it's too expensive, and
I think it takes too long time.
And we have all kinds
of reasons to do
something don't let do that.
So for me, the sky is the limit
and thinking is the creation
and doing this feeling and
then making is the learning.
And I want to tell you a
little story about what
happened to me 14 years ago.
I saw a hot air balloon
and I was in my car
and I was reading a
little bit and had
jazz music in the background.
And I thought, hey, Eureka.
The balloon is actually a hot
air oven, a very big hot air
oven.
Do you have experience
in a hot air balloon?
Yes?
OK.
You have once been in a
hot air balloon, yeah?
Everybody almost.
Oh, that sounds great.
So imagine the balloon
is a hot air oven.
So what will happen
when you put something
in it like a sea bass
or a half a chicken
or some mussels
or some paprikash?
Will it be cooked?
Well, I can say to myself
at the same moment,
no, it is too dangerous or maybe
somebody else did it already.
But I stayed in my
dream and my fantasy
to think, oh, when
it's possible,
then we can make a restaurant
with the most wonderful view
you can imagine around small
villages and small rivers.
You go low and you go high so
you have the restaurants which
is wonderful.
And so I keep on dreaming.
And then I called a
guy from a company.
I said, hey, can I
ask you something?
Is it possible to go once
with you in the balloon
and put something in it?
He was a little bit
quiet at that moment.
You said, yes,
come to my company
and we'll go together in
the air and let's try it.
So I had small bags with
small chickens and a sea bass
and then they filled the
balloon with cold air
and then we walked
in the balloon
and put all the small bags
inside of the balloon.
And then went go up and then
we say, do you smell already
something?
It's too big to smell something.
And then afterwards,
the idea grows.
That's what happened.
You get used to the idea and
then the idea gets the normal
and then you want more.
So I said, we can
go with one balloon,
but what will happen when we
put three balloons together
and we have 50 persons
in three balloons
and we go up about one
and a half kilometers?
I don't know how many
feet it is, but it's high.
And we do a three-course
menu in the air.
They say, it sounds wonderful.
And then we get more
used to the idea
and then we say, we put two
chefs on the top of the balloon
and they go up
sailing on the outside
and give me the main course.
Yes, that would be wonderful.
So we are all so excited.
We are really excited, saying,
whoa, that would be wonderful.
And then we jumped
out of the balloon
to make the desert in the meadow
before the balloons are landed.
Sounds wonderful, eh?
Do you think it' real?
Do you think it happened?
That's a good attitude.
That's great.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
So for me, a brainstorm is
not anymore a brainstorm.
For me, it's a dreamstorm.
It's like a hypercreativity.
And you have to be sometimes
hypercreative to be different
or to reach some things you
never thought you could reach.
And now Lucas is going to
show the movie of the three
balloons connected
with 50 persons
one and a half kilometers high.
A three-course menu
in an hour and a half.
So that's me a
little bit younger.
OK.
So these are the two
chefs who are going
on the top of the balloon.
It was the biggest balloon
in Europe at that time,
for 24 persons.
Three balloons
connected and we go up.
This is a very short movie.
And this is about one and
a half kilometers high.
He's on top of the balloon.
And the temperature
in the balloon
is about 90 degrees Celsius.
So you need a converter
to put it in--
OK.
So you can measure two chefs
on the top of the balloon.
When the balloon is
already half filled,
they go up and on the top
there's a small opening.
They can check how my food is.
And this is the system from one
balloon to the other balloon.
So we had one kitchen balloon
and two restaurant balloons.
In one kitchen balloon,
everything was cooked
and then it goes down
with a pulley system.
And then it goes to
the other balloons
where there was a chef to
prepare it for the guests.
So here is the three-course
menu for 50 persons.
And then he had to move
on the top of the balloon
because it was very hot.
Because he were
standing still, it was--
so he had to move around.
So this is the first dish.
This is a Dorada with
vinaigrette and cucumber.
It's wonderful.
It was so high.
And now he's going up
sailing with the main course
on the outside.
And they say, oh my god, it
was so hot upstairs there.
It was so warm.
There goes the second guy.
And then after the
main course, it
was chicken stuffed with duck.
And we served it
with some mushrooms
and some green asparagus.
So then they disconnected
the three balloons
and you see each
balloon is going.
And then they jump out
to prepare the dessert.
OK.
Thank you, Lucas.
For me, this is the example
of believing in every idea you
have, in every dream.
And go on and take action
because when I said that idea,
ah, it might be too dangerous
or I called an insurance company
and they said, oh, you
have to insure yourself.
Well, what will happen when
the balloon will crash?
So it's not necessary
to insure yourself.
But for the other guests also.
OK.
So this is me in my kitchen.
This is my view from the
kitchen with a lobster salad.
Nice view.
This is the kitchen.
It looks as if the
balloon is in the Alps,
but this is actually a picture
made from another balloon.
It was in Austria, and we
made a trip of four hours.
And I made 12 dishes
above the Alps.
It was very exciting.
This is above the clouds.
So the sun is shining
above the clouds
and then you go
through the clouds
and then it's very quiet.
And then you eat
your lobster there.
So for me, everything I do
is coming right at my heart,
and I believed in that
already a long time ago.
I was a chef with a Michelin
star in the restaurant
and then I thought, OK, do I
want to do this my whole life?
Oh, yes, maybe, but not
only in a restaurant.
So my dream was to
tell more about flavors
and to travel and
to do crazy things
and to give experience to
people, but not an experience
because it's like marketing,
but experience which is real,
an authentic experience.
And for me, experience
is economy, but only when
it's a meaningful experience.
So these are the most mentioned
idea killers like it might work
in other places, but not here.
And this is the worst one,
since when are you the expert?
When you say that to someone,
they say, oh, next time I
don't want to mention my idea.
You are familiar with this,
with the idea killers?
And the opposite of the idea
killers are the idea boosters--
just do it and go experiment.
So don't shoot.
You don't have a
license to kill ideas.
Years.
This is my message
always in the kitchen.
So you have to try
a lot of things.
Also, everybody has a flavor
reference and a flavor memory
from your childhood, from
the soup your grandma made
or the stew.
And when you love food,
it's in your memory.
And therefore, it's important
to try a lot of things
so you can make it even better.
Well, now it's about temptation.
And I want to tell you about a
carrot, just a simple carrot.
And if I looked at a
carrot, I think, oh, you're
just a carrot.
You see the rabbit.
He's laughing at the
carrot because we're always
using the carrot as a
salad or in soup or stew,
as we do in Holland.
But the challenge is to make
a carrot a golden carrot,
like gold, to give
it much more value.
And when I was a chef
in the restaurants
and I had to make a new menu
card, it was until one, two,
three o'clock in the night and
I was thinking, I have a dish.
But sometimes I missed that one
little accent which a dish can
make very special, timeless.
So sometimes you're
in a restaurant
and you say, oh,
this is very nice.
And another time, you
say, this is one of them,
you will never
forget the flavor.
Have you had that experience?
Sometimes it's OK and
the other time, you
say, oh, I wish I could
go back to that restaurant
and experience it again.
That's what I mean.
As a chef, I think
it's important
that you create dishes
that guests will remember
and they will come back for.
So I was always thinking,
thinking, thinking.
Sometimes you have
it in a split second.
You say, OK, I missed
maybe a little bit of lemon
or maybe a little star anise or
maybe some seaweed, whatever.
But when you make
a transference--
when you say, I'm
missing something
and you make inspiration
transference,
films a whole world of
possibilities and flavors
is opened.
One logical thing is
most people can only
remember certain things
from the short memory.
So when I say to you, carrots,
just think of a carrot.
Which are the best flavor
friends of a carrot?
Just name some.
What do you eat--
ginger, thank you.
Come on.
Lemon, thank you.
Cinnamon.
Yes great.
It's a great match,
cinnamon and carrots.
Garlic.
Yeah, Yeah.
OK.
We are already here with
about 30 and four things.
OK.
Cumin.
What did you say?
almonds.
Yeah.
Laurel.
Great.
You prepared.
AUDIENCE: Mint.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Mint, yes.
So you know what
is happening now?
You have to think, oh,
and just the things
we know that match with the
carrots are in the front
because maybe you just tasted
or you had just a salad with it.
But then you have
to search for more.
And that's a good thing to
know in creativity, that you
can just remember seven things.
So when you say, where is
the inspiration coming from,
it's for chefs, from memories,
from dishes you already ate
or from your family
or our restaurants
or a market, cookbooks,
magazines, internet,
television.
But for a chef,
it's very important
to let you get
inspired by the season.
Take the best characteristics
of a wonderful carrot.
I go in my mind
traveling to the sea.
I think, oh, what can the
sea offer me in this season?
Maybe a nice squid or
maybe some anchovies.
So I'm looking for flavors which
I think, oh, the carrot will
be happy from that.
So if you are a carrot,
what makes you happy?
That's the way a chef thinks.
I'm traveling in my mind
to a land or to fashion.
Fashion is a big inspiration
for matching flavors and colors.
So later on, I will
make the carrot
with a very concentrated
tomato puree
and then you see that
colors can be inspired.
Just look around you
at fashion or art.
It's not only the colors
in art, but it's also
when you look at this painting,
what will this painting tell
you?
You see a lot of depth,
you see a lot of colors.
There All warm colors
and cold colors.
And then if you take a look
for a couple of minutes,
then you get some emotion and
when you trust on that emotion,
you can use it in your
flavor composition.
Well, so now again,
you love to cook.
And then we think
again of the carrots,
what can I do with carrots?
These are preparations.
These are all kinds of
things I cannot remember.
As a chef, I can also
remember seven, maybe 10.
But when I say, oh, hey, it's
a good idea to braise a carrot
or to ferment it or to put it
on a barbecue or I marinate it
or I deep fry it or
make it in a papillote--
in a foil with some garlic
and oil and rosemary--
or I inject it.
Oh, yeah, of course you
know you can inject carrots.
So when I have like a
needle, I can put it
in and [SPEAKING DUTCH]?
PETER KLOSSE: Siphon.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Yeah.
And then get all flavors
to inject it and then
put it in the oven.
And then all the aromas are
going between the carrot.
Or I can smoke it.
So there's a lot
more possible when
you make inspiration visible.
And these are just word clouds.
You know word clouds
from the internet.
For me, a word cloud is a lot
of inspiration for techniques.
These are preparations,
techniques.
You can make a bavarois
or a cream from a carrot
or I could make an ice
cream or a soup or a syrup.
I can make a spring
roll, en espuma, flan.
There's so much that I can do
to give this carrot so much more
value.
Another thing is I can travel
in my mind to another culture.
So this is Morocco.
And when you travel and
you go to the markets--
who's gone to the markets?
Everybody?
OK.
And then you see all the
flavors and the spices
and the herbs and the
fruits and the veggies.
And then when you
close your eyes
and you go with the carrots, you
go to the market in Marrakesh
and you say, OK, so
star anise and the lemon
and the sort of grapefruits
and the oranges.
I see so many things.
That's what you can do
in your imagination.
But sometimes we say, oh,
that's a little bit crazy
and we laugh about it.
But this really brings you a lot
of ideas to travel in your mind
to countries where
you've been, countries
which you have inspired.
Like when we think
of a carrot and we
want to combine it with
Chinese ingredients, what
do you think of?
Chinese kitchen.
Soy sauce, oyster sauce,
rice wine, rice vinegar.
More Chinese.
Chinese.
You're from China?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm not.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: But garlic?
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Garlic.
Yeah.
Chinese kitchen.
come on.
Join in.
Cinnamon also.
Yeah.
Anise, yeah.
Well.
We go on.
Now we go to Italy.
Who has been in Italy?
OK, great.
So when we think of a carrot
in an Italian kitchen,
where do you think of?
Italian kitchen maybe close
by in your flavor memory.
Italian kitchen, come on.
Red wine.
Red, red wine.
Think of basil, tomatoes.
Yes?
Olive oil.
Come on. come on, you can do it.
AUDIENCE: Parmesan.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Parmesan
cheese, prosciutto, porcini.
Think of what fish you know the
Italian kitchen you have often
on a pizza.
Oregano, anchovies.
So Parmesan, prosciutto,
anchovies, sardines.
It's all Italian
kitchen, Italian cuisine.
What will happen
when you tempt fate,
produce the carrots with all
of these different ingredients?
You get a different carrot.
So that's a little
bit of my message.
And for the painting, this
is the painting in my head.
From all the traveling I
did from all the countries,
I think, oh, I have the
carrot and the tomato
and I have the
ginger and seaweed.
I have the [INAUDIBLE] spices,
saffron, I have fennel seeds,
I have the dill, and I
have even the coffee beans.
When you crush coffee beans,
you have a lot of flavor.
Well, what will happen
when you make a carrot cake
and put some coffee flavorings?
OK.
So this has happened
in my head as a chef.
And these are the
dishes then I have made.
It's a yogurt ice cream
with roasted orange paprika
with mango and
chips of carrots--
chips of carrot not deep
fried, bits dried in the oven
at 70 degrees.
This is the inspiration
from Marrakesh,
carrot salad with lentils with
a reduction of orange juice
and ras el hanout.
You know ras el hanout?
The best spice mix from
the spice men there.
And some peas.
SPEAKER: Chickpeas.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
Chickpeas cream.
Yeah, and some mint.
So this is just a combination in
my inspiration from Marrakesh.
OK.
This is a ceviche with
quinoa, coriander.
This is the Chinese inspiration.
This is with tuna and a roll
with a very think carrot
with [INAUDIBLE], seaweed.
And I made a dressing from
a reduction of orange juice.
Tempura of carrots.
This is very important.
In this dish, you have from
one carrot four preparations.
So the whole carrot
was in the oven
and then all the juices in
the carrot are caramelizing.
And then I cut it and it
didn't touch any water
so it's full of flavor.
Then I made around the carrots
a marinated carrots julienne.
Then I made a mousseline
of the rest of the carrot
with some olive oil
and some lemon juice
because lemon is bringing all
the flavor more intensity, more
alive.
And then a crunch.
So when you think
of these flavors,
you have sweet of the carrots,
you have the smooth mouth feel
of the cream, you have the
balance of the sweet and sour
from the marinated carrots,
and you have crunch.
So this is what you can do with
one ingredient, one veggie,
to [INAUDIBLE].
These are all veggies
marinated and rolled up.
OK.
Well, before I'm going
to make the painting,
this is a flavor graphic.
You can make a flavor
graphic yourself.
Think, oh, I use an
onion in this case.
Oh, which spice do I
like or which spices
can I match with an onion and
what can I do with the onion?
We cannot remember these,
so when you draw it and make
your own word cloud or mind
map, a whole worlds is going
to open.
OK.
Sorry.
Next one.
Yeah.
OK.
This is the last thing before
I'm going to make the painting.
When we talk about
the success factors--
and we'll ask Peter here--
stand here, it's a
little bit better.
Peter will tell more
about the success factors
because it will
help you every time
when you go visit a
restaurant, eat a dish,
or you make your own dish.
Because there are a couple of
not rules, but a couple of--
how do you say it?
PETER KLOSSE: They are
rules, rules of composition.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
Rules of composition.
And when you hear this,
you will never forget it
because it will make every visit
to a restaurant and every dish
you make, it will
be made different.
PETER KLOSSE: So the
thing Angélique is saying,
you need imagination.
With imagination, you got all
these wonderful combinations
of things.
And then there is
also kind of a theory.
So you need a kind of a theory
to bring it all together.
And that's what
this slide shows us.
For one is because
it's very special.
Umami is, of course, called
one of the basic flavors.
Umami is a very rich
family of four flavors.
One of the culinary
success factors
is that umami should be there.
So if a dish lacks umami,
there's something missing.
This is what
Angélique is saying.
So knowing about umami
is very important.
This is the other
important side of it,
knowing about what every
component does in a dish.
So we think that flavor is
basically about mouth fell,
and in mouth feel there
are three different forces.
One force we call contracting.
It has everything to do with
salt, with acidity, with sour,
things that contract
in your mouth.
That's why we chose
the word contracted.
Another direction, another
force is called the coating.
And this is about all the
fats and all the sugars
and everything that really
leaves a layer behind
in your mouth.
And then there is another
vector, another force,
that's called
drying or dry, which
is basically the crunch or
everything that has a texture--
things that you can chew on,
things that you can bite on,
things like that.
So these are different
forces and this
is the basic composition
of every flavor
throughout the world.
When I was in Beijing, I gave
a master class in Beijing
and then all these
Chinese people exactly
understood what I was
talking about within
their cultural frame of flavor.
So it's very important,
I think, to realize
that flavor has a
real structure and I
call them vectors and these
are real vectors with forces
behind them.
Of course, we don't have a
measure for these forces,
that's what we need to develop.
It would be wonderful
to have a scale,
but we don't have
these scales yet.
But I think these scales
will be developed.
Smart people at Google should
be able to do that for sure.
But this could be the basis
of any algorithm or flavor.
So now we are going
to go back to practice
in building the painting.
So Angélique.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
PETER KLOSSE: So I
will tell every time
if it's coating, crunch,
or frying, or whatever.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Exactly.
PETER KLOSSE: That's
what I will do.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Yeah.
So this is the pumpkin
and the sweet potato
in the oven with lot of
bay leaf and garlic--
roasting, roasting, roasting.
Then I've pureed it.
And it's not sweet,
but it's coating,
but it's full of flavor with
a little white wine vinegar
to lift it up.
Excuse me.
And this will be kind of
the basic for the paint.
Oops.
PETER KLOSSE: So coating, right?
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: I'm going
to ask some chefs to help me.
PETER KLOSSE: You're going to
be able to taste everything.
So you will see that there
is a bit of acidity in it,
because otherwise it
would be too coated.
So the acidity works as
a countervailing power
within the cooking,
so within the puree.
That's what
composition is about.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Yeah.
Yeah because some-- it's a
little bit thinner because I
made it this morning.
So I'll do it a little
bit different now.
If you'll stay here, we'll
give you some other--
so you put big dots.
Take your time.
Take a nice dot like
this and then up.
Just on every plate some dots.
OK?
OK.
Now, this is a curd
of kefir yogurt.
I made a [INAUDIBLE]
with some miso.
And miso is from soybean paste.
PETER KLOSSE: Fermented.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
Fermented soybean paste.
And every Japanese
family has its own miso.
So it's a little bit salty and
it's a very nice combination
together with the curds.
Yeah, great.
PETER KLOSSE: Again,
a coating substance.
And if you taste it, you
will find the acidity.
So that balance of why, a bit
of the richness of the coating.
So it's the balance you
find within the substance.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: So just
put it like this, nice dots.
Yes.
And follow the line.
Yeah?
And this is some cuds, too,
but it's mixed with saffron
to make it more [INAUDIBLE].
I need a small [INAUDIBLE].
PETER KLOSSE: We did work
on culinary success factors.
For instance, at Google
in London and Paris
and Zurich and Dublin, we
worked with Google chefs.
We developed dishes based on
the culinary success factors.
Then they were served at
Google offices for Googlers
and then we asked, which one
of the three alternatives
did you like best?
And every time, you
find that the ones that
have the culinary
success factors
are found to be without any
information just naturally
the best.
It's very interesting
to have a re-evaluation
of these culinary
success factors.
Presentation is a
very important one.
So the way things
look, the presentation
of a dish, the name you give a
dish is all a part of flavor.
It's often forgotten.
People think that flavor is
sweet, sour, bitter, et cetera,
but it's much, much, much more.
You need to take everything into
account to really understand
what flavor is about.
So the name, presentation, color
is an important aspect of it.
Balance is an important aspect,
smell is an important aspect,
umami is one, and very
identifiable flavors as well.
And then you need a
balance in mouth feel,
differences in mouth feel.
We're going to work on that.
These are all let's say
the coating substances.
But you will find
that we need more
to make a nice balance
and a nice dish
or a canvas or a painting.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
Then we have the tomato.
And the tomato will mix
together with the sweetness
of the sweet potato and pumpkin.
PETER KLOSSE: Tomato is
a very special ingredient
because there are many
flavors within a tomato.
If you have a say
early harvested
tomato or an unripe type, then
the acidity and the tartness
will be there.
But when you have a very rich
tomato which is harvested late,
then of course, it will be
much sweeter and much richer.
So it's very important to
look at what type of tomato
you have for the effect
that you want to use.
If you want to have
something sweet,
then you need a riper type
of tomato and a sweeter
one than if you just wanted
the tartness or the acidity.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
Then we have a very
wonderful ingredient
which you will smell.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
It's fermented spices and
veggies from the Indian kitchen
like fenugreek,
onion, garlic, curry
leaves and is very strong.
So I heated it to 40
degrees Celsius, mixed it
with sunflower and olive oil.
And it will be connecting
because it's not spicy,
but it's full of flavor.
PETER KLOSSE: It is part
of the second factor
that I mentioned, the smell
of a dish is very important.
By using an oil like this,
you have a very rich flavor
component and you will notice
that within seconds, everything
will smell like the [INAUDIBLE].
It's an important aspect.
I already have it in my nose.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
Then for the crunch--
a juicy crunch-- we use
the leaves of endive.
And you can use it later
like a kind of a spoon
and then with the
endive you pick up
the cream like a crunch.
We need a crunch, Peter.
PETER KLOSSE: Also
this is a balance.
The mouth feel needs
to be interesting.
So you need crunchy,
you need bites,
you need things that
crack, things that break.
You need every kind of
crunch that your mouth
can make things interesting.
If you only had the
creamy substances,
it will be kind of boring.
So now we're going to add
different types of mouth feel.
So here you have the
leaves that break and make
a high-pitched sound, which
is much more like crispy.
There are going to be nuts,
there are going to be crisps.
They're all
different mouth feels
that really help to make
a flavor in balance.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
Do you already smell that?
OK.
Let's say the oxygen is coming
a little bit to the flavors.
PETER KLOSSE: Imagine that
this oil wouldn't be there.
The dish would be less
interesting, right?
It's the smell that does that.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
Now we have a green oil--
not just a green oil.
It is made from flat
parsley and tarragon.
Tarragon there's a
lot of anise flavor.
And often, when you
make an herb oil,
it's going to [INAUDIBLE]
in some brown-green color.
And we blanch it first
just in water without salt
and put it in, pull it
out at the same time,
make it cold very quickly.
We squeeze out all
the water and then
we mix it with 40 degree Celsius
oil until it's like this.
And it's the chlorophyll
which makes the oil much more
intense then when it's raw.
OK.
PETER KLOSSE: Look at what the
color does on the painting.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Oops.
PETER KLOSSE: Part
of presentation.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: So when you
are going to eat this later on,
you have to mix a lot of things.
But it will happen
at the same time
because everything
is going to connect.
PETER KLOSSE: The tarragon and
the parsley are fresh flavors
and they are often
confounded with sour.
It's very important to
distinguish freshness
from sourness.
Freshness and sourness do
go together once in a while,
but in an oil like this
it's just freshness
that you have
without the sourness.
So that really does
influence the mouth feel
on the contracting
side that's the coating
but also gives freshness.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
So now, we were
talking about carrots.
And this is the purple carrot.
For me, this is an example
of how to seduce a carrots.
Well, it's not that
difficult. You just
put it in the oven for a long
time with a lot of bay leaves.
I think this carrot had
about six bay leaves crushed.
So a lot of flavor can
come out of the bay leaf.
A lot of garlic.
Then we first blanch it so
that the plant cells can open
and then all the sweet
juices can caramelize.
And it's in the oven
on 160 degrees Celsius.
Sorry.
Next time I will have it
with Fahrenheit in my head.
And then roast, roast, roast.
And it's going to
flavor like licorice.
You know licorice?
In Holland we are
fond of licorice.
So this carrot is
like licorice, just
the carrot with
three ingredients.
And I did it with just
one orange carrot.
And it's quite different.
It's more caramelized
and it's less
intensive than the purple one.
So for every one I
have one piece, yes?
So if you like it, just
please take one piece.
Otherwise, I don't
think we'll have enough.
And we have a whole
carrot to combine it
with all the other
flavors on the dish.
So it's nice to--
PETER KLOSSE: Have a
carrot and pass it through.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Yeah.
PETER KLOSSE: I think one
of the things in gastronomy
that people forget a lot
is to cook vegetables.
Vegetables, a lot of
times they are raw.
And if you eat them
raw, they are raw.
And there is a lot more flavor
to find in carrots or whatever
vegetable when you
add temperature.
And often here as
well, when I'm here,
I'm often surprised at all the
things that are involved here--
kale and sprouts.
And much of these things
are much, much better
when they've been cooked.
And then you can eat them,
of course, cold if you want.
But cooking vegetables
at lower temperatures
and getting these flavors
out is a very important side
of the flavor story
of vegetables.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
This is a freshly
made tomato puree from
tomatoes with onions
and cooked to reduce all
the water until it's thick.
And then we put
it in the blender
and then you have
your own fresh puree
from good ripened tomatoes.
And this is the color blocking
that you see in fashion when
you have an orange shirt with
a red trouser and you go, whoa.
So in flavor, it's the same.
The carrot is very sweet and the
tomato is a little bit of acid
so it will give much
more life to all things.
It's often when you miss
something in this, then
start with adding
a little bit maybe
some caper or a little
bit of sour tomato puree.
PETER KLOSSE: Acidity
is often forgotten.
Acidity is one of the most
forgotten parts of a dish,
including bitter.
Bitter and acidity,
it is thought
that people don't like those
things and they're kept away.
But for depth and for
having great dishes,
you need a good addition of some
acidity and some bitterness--
not too much, but a bit.
It's like salt, it's good to
add a bit but not too much.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
Let's do the olives.
Fresh olives, dried olives.
OK.
We have kalamata
olives, fresh once.
Do you know them?
When you chew, much more
flavors will come to you
when you are aware of
what you're eating.
But then see the difference,
flavor the difference
of dried kalamata olives.
We're putting both
on the painting
so we can experiment with what
is happening when you pull out
all the liquids.
It's a very strange flavor.
I don't think you've ever
flavored like this an olive.
It's so intense.
It's a little bit bitter--
just a little bit-- and
a little bit more salty.
OK.
What we will do is if you put
just a little bit, so here
and there.
Yeah?
And these ones we
put a little together
so it's in the same area
so you can taste both.
OK.
Let me see what I have.
We do the same with the capers.
We have the fresh capers,
you all know them?
And when you dry
the fresh capers
in the oven at 70
degrees Celsius,
so don't be in a hurry.
The oven is doing the job.
And you dry it, you get a
crunchy, acid ingredient.
It's very nice.
It's a very nice flavor.
We put it next to
each other again
so you can flavor
the difference.
Yeah.
OK.
PETER KLOSSE: Of
course, you understand
what you're doing with
drying things in the oven.
You intensify flavors and
in intensifying flavors,
you're also changing flavors.
So you're reducing the
sharpness of the raw caper.
It has a very sharp acidity.
And if you taste
the dried one, it's
much more on the salty side.
So the whole
profile of the caper
is changing by, again,
adding temperature.
And if you think that's a lot of
work, let the oven do the work.
You can do your own thing
while the oven is working.
You don't have to stand next to
it, you don't have to help it,
you don't have to look at it.
It just works by itself.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: OK.
But we have more.
Yeah.
We have the furikake.
It's from a Japanese kitchen.
It's a topping
usually used for rice.
And I made it myself.
It's from seaweed, roasted
sesame seed-- white ones--
the black ones and wasabi
flavored ones with [INAUDIBLE]..
I heat it in the pan.
Dried capers are also in it.
And it's a really
nice crunchy mix.
I'm going to put it on the
side of the curd with the miso
because they're a
little bit friends.
And then you take a little
bit of endive with the miso
curd and then with
the furikake and you
have a wonderful combination.
PETER KLOSSE: Leave
that to your assistants.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Yeah.
OK.
So we're almost there.
PETER KLOSSE: Nuts.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Yeah, nuts.
Something I will leave
here because it's getting
a little bit too busy on the--
first we do the crunch.
We have a cracker I
made from tapioca flour
with saffron and water.
Spread it out, dry it,
and then I deep fry it.
And the crunch is
important in a dish.
Without a crunch, a dish can
be very sometimes boring.
The crunch we put on
the saffron cream.
Just put it down,
don't put it in.
OK.
And we have the same
with a seaweed cracker
also made from tapioca
and with crunched seaweed.
We put it on the miso, not
everywhere but here and there.
Then we have more.
We have the walnuts,
just plain walnuts.
It's a different crunch than
endive or than the saffron
crackers.
And I put that crunch
also with the curds.
PETER KLOSSE: These
are all elements
that belong to the drying
components in the plate.
But evidently, the nuts
are different in mouth
feel than the crispness of
the saffron and the seaweed.
Then we have that one.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: This
is a very important one.
You know the toastie?
You ever have a toastie?
You know the bread with
the cheese and the ham
and then the cheese is coming
on the outside of the bread?
You know that?
And then you get that smell
from the caramelized cheese?
Well, this is the crunchy part
of the sides of the toastie.
Yes?
This is wonderful.
You only need this
when you flavor it
with the sweet potato
and the tomato.
And then you have all
the Italian umami flavors
you can imagine.
PETER KLOSSE: You can
imagine it's Parmesan,
but probably everybody
knows it's Parmesan.
Together with tomato, of
course, it's wonderful.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Just
a couple and then the rest
we'll do separate.
Just a couple.
Yeah.
OK.
We're almost there.
Let me see.
We This is very rich.
These are algae crackers--
not LG from the television,
but algae from the sea.
Very thin very strong.
Don't eat it at the
beginning because it
stays very long in your mouth.
OK.
Can you put some?
Yeah.
OK.
I see one thing as a chef
because there's a camera
and I have a very
awful dot here.
Yes, you see?
OK.
Then we leave this a
little bit separate.
I started with the
carrots and I will almost
end with the carrots.
But first when we
talk about no waste,
you can make powder from every
ingredient you can imagine.
So when you have
leftover from veggies,
just dry them in the
oven and then put it
in like a coffee bean
machine, the small thing.
You know them here?
Very quick one?
Grinder Grinder.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK:
Grinder, yes.
And then you can make
a wonderful powder.
So I put some powder--
let's see [INAUDIBLE]----
just to finish.
PETER KLOSSE: You end
up with green hair.
ANGELIQUE SCHMEINCK: Yeah.
It's awesome, yeah?
OK.
Now I have filthy hands.
And then we end where we
started, with the carrots.
You see what's happening.
The algae powder is
mixing with the carrots.
Nice, eh?
Yeah.
That's what's happening.
The carrot power
I made from when
you use the carrots in the
juicer, then in the container
the pulp that's remaining,
just grind the pulp.
And you have a
wonderful kind of powder
which you can use in a
patisserie or in a dough
or in dressings.
OK.
The other side.
And it actually adds
a lot of flavor.
OK.
I forgot one thing.
I have to sign.
I have to sign it.
I have to sign
the painting, yes?
So I say go on Google.
So it's for you.
[APPLAUSE]
I would like to invite you
to come around the painting
and just experience
all the combinations.
So bon appetit.
[APPLAUSE]